all right we're here at kcon and we are
about to see itsy take the stage and we
have a lot of fans waiting to see them
are y'all excited to see itsy
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's up everybody it's Warren a
lot of you have always been asking me to
do a vlog a lot of you have also asked
me things like what I'm passionate about
outside of Marvel and superheroes and a
lot of you have always asked me what
kind of music I like so in this video
I'm going to cover all of that as I got
a chance to attend kcon 2022 in LA and
it's actually pretty surreal I got a
chance to interact with some of my
favorite artists of all time including
meeting the leader of my favorite group
yeji from itsy now kcon was pretty great
because I personally had the opportunity
to work around some of my favorite
groups like I mentioned like itsy and
Stacy it was an honor to work with them
and as you can see from some of these
videos I was pretty dang close
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
fans went pretty crazy to see their
favorite artists and I was geeking out a
lot myself as well
[Music]
and it was a really fun time and a
really great opportunity that I'm very
thankful for now one thing that wasn't
provided with my invitation to kcon was
a artist engagement and I didn't really
know what to expect but I bought it
anyways just to see what the process
would be like and of course I bought it
for my favorite group itsy what I bought
was called a high touch and before the
pandemic that meant that you could walk
up to your favorite group and give them
a high five and talk to them for like a
second but unfortunately because of the
pandemic they put a glass between the
two of you so instead you just kind of
walk by them and wave at them or in my
case I would put my hand in half a heart
shape against the glass and they
actually completed the heart with their
hand putting it against the glass as
well it was definitely really cool and
it was really great to see them up close
in person like that and I definitely
think especially if there's no glass
there at Future K cons if you're a fan
of the artist there and you want to meet
them this is actually a pretty cool
experience but luckily for me I had the
chance to interact with them outside of
that high touch now with the high touch
actually comes what they call a meet and
greet which is where the artists stand
on stage and you're in the crowd and
they basically talk to you and they play
some games as you can see here
[Music]
joke around you get to see them laugh
and kind of just get to see them in a
different light than you're used to
now the rest of the convention was
actually really really awesome they have
a lot of vendor booths from beauty
products to clothing to album boxes that
you can buy and there's a lot of
interactive things that you can do there
as well and the cool part is is randomly
artists will simply show up at some
booths around 500.
and on top of that there's a lot of
great food there's a lot of different
things you can participate in like tons
of different dance groups
[Music]
and of course there is amazing food at
some of the booths that you can get as
well
now they also have panels and they also
have workshops at the panels you can see
some of your favorite artists and some
of the famous influencers in the
community talk about K-pop and the k-con
community I actually had the chance to
meet and talk to Kevin Wu he was really
really awesome and his panel was awesome
as well
[Music]
I also had the chance to meet Isabelle
an influencer in the community and she
was soon and then some of the workshops
they have are things like teaching you
how to start a K-pop YouTube channel or
teaching you how to build something
K-pop related of course and there's just
a ton of fun things that you can do at
this convention it's definitely worth it
if you are a K-pop fan
[Music]
now one of the coolest things is that
the convention ends with a concert on
night two and three Saturday and Sunday
and the concert is really cool because
it has a lot of different artists at the
same concert each night so it's not a
concert for just one of your favorite
artists but it's a concert for a lot of
them for example the concert on the
first night on Saturday had stray kids
and itsy and they are two of my all-time
favorite groups ever and the second
night had some amazing artists as well
such as Luna and ZT dream Stacy inmix
Tia one it was awesome and at the end of
the concert all the artists actually go
on stage together and they all wave
goodbye and it's really cool to see them
all together
overall kcon was a pretty incredible
experience I'm really glad that I got to
interact with some of my favorite
artists and it's something that I
definitely want to go back to next year
as a huge fan of K-pop and the K-pop
Community this was really really fun and
I definitely want to go back to next
year and recommend anybody who loves
Kpop to try it out as well well thanks
for watching my Vlog about kcon 2022 in
La I will catch you all next time in the
next Marvel superhero video thanks for
watching wolf wolf